hanck great video and Wednesday thanks
for reminding us that nerdfighting is
important but it also needs to be fun
anyway Hank you've inspired me to make
my video today about something fun st.
so right now that we've been brothers
for almost 30 years you know pretty much
everything about me but one thing you
may not know is that even though I am
myself not Catholic
I am completely obsessed with Catholic
patron saints patron saints are Saints
that are associated with a place or an
ailment or a career and you can ask
those Saints to advocate on your behalf
in heaven
so for example the patron saint of
hemorrhoids or I guess the patron saint
against hemorrhoids is st. fiora who is
also the patron saint of cab drivers who
due to the sitting and driving
frequently get hemorrhoids ergo he is
the patron saint of hemorrhoids against
hemorrhoids another example is that st.
Clare of Assisi is the patron saint of
television because when she was lying in
bed near her death too sick to go to
Mass the mass broadcast itself on her
wall like a celestial flatscreen so when
your cable goes out you ask st. Claire
to see if she can talk to the big man
about whether anything can be done now
that probably seems completely crazy to
you but I would argue that the other
strategy calling your local cable
provider is even less likely to be
effective anyway who you pick as your
patron saint is important for instance
st. Clare of Assisi the affer mentioned
patron saint of television is not a
patron saint of children which perhaps
explains this famous painting of her
commonly called st. Claire saving a
child from a wolf although to the child
in question the painting might be known
as st. Claire showing up just a little
bit late visiter my left arm and it's
attachment to my body but that's the
risk you run when you pray to Saint
Claire not a patron saint of children to
intercede on behalf of a child and who
knows Hank the outcome might have been
different if the intercession er had
been for instance st. Nicholas of Myra
aka the original santa claus who you
will notice is not white pepper
downstrokes so anyway Hank st. Nicholas
of Myra is remembered as a patron saint
of children because he once resurrected
three children who had been murdered and
pickled and brine so what I'm saying
Hank is that it's vitally important to
pick the right patron saint and as of
yet there is no patron saint of YouTube
now you could go with Saint Claire she's
well established in the screen field
she's done a great job with television
or you could go with Isidora Seville who
despite dying in the year 636 is somehow
the patron saint of computer
but Hank I am going to recommend a
relatively recent Saint to in a lot of
people's opinion was a little bit nutty
Padre Pio and yes I keep him in my
wallet Padre Pio was a twentieth-century
Italian priest who had the stigmata or
burned himself with acid repeatedly on
purpose depending on your perspective
and Hank Padre Pio is famous partly
because he is said to have had the gift
of bilocation which means that he could
be in two places at the same time he
could be at the pizza hut and he could
be at the Taco Bell without being at the
combination Pizza Hut and Taco Bell
that's a neat trick but thanks to
YouTube isn't it a superpower we all now
have I mean Here I am in my basement in
Indiana tandem at your house in Missoula
actually I have tri location because I'm
also currently located on my own chest
Hank on Monday you'll be in both
Indianapolis in Missoula I look forward
to it
patron saints are Saints they're
associated with a particular place or in
Willie what was the one rule about you
being able to watch filming it was that
you wouldn't make noise with your caller